foreign
[Music]
with Google Cloud I'm developer Advocate
caslin fields and today we're going to
explore observability with chronosphere
to walk us through it today we have Matt
schallert would you introduce yourself
Matt yeah hi cousin thanks for having me
uh my name is Matt and I'm a software
engineer at chronosphere where I work to
make sure that our infrastructure meets
the scale and reliability demands of our
customers awesome so tell us a little
bit more about chronosphere what does
chronosphere do chronosphere is a
software as a service observability
company built for cloud native
environments and it was created to help
other companies solve some of the same
problems that our Founders saw while
building the observability platform at
Uber okay we'll get more into that a
little bit later I think but first what
is the specific product that we're going
to be talking about today yeah the
product that we're talking about is uh
our one product our observability
platform and we ingest both metric and
Trace data to let users debug issues
more quickly and reduce the amount of
time uh that their own end users are
impacted and really spend less time
managing their observability systems and
more time building what differentiates
them as a business so we ingest uh
Telemetry data in a variety of Open
Source formats such as Prometheus and
open Telemetry which really helps with
onboarding and avoiding vendor lock-in
and then we put users in control of how
that data is ingested how it's stored
and for how long so that they can really
remain in control of their observability
costs while uh their systems grow and
you mentioned that the founders of
chronosphere came up with this idea
based on on their own experiences could
you talk a little bit more about that
yeah definitely uh so the founders were
helping build the observability platform
at Uber which really was ahead of its
time in terms of compute and
observability practices and adopting
kind of a cloud native mindset but the
team also saw a lot of the complexity
that these new architectures and new
patterns were placing on observability
systems so now uh you know instead of
having kind of like a few fixed number
of VMS running a single application each
you have thousands of containers
emitting all this data and it really
puts a lot of kind of complexity and
scale demands on your observability
systems so when uh when the team kind of
saw these problems that Uber was facing
they kind of were able to see where you
know the rest of the industry was going
and some of the problems that they would
be encountering and apply those lessons
in building chronosphere but I can also
say as someone that also worked on that
observability platform that uh building
and maintaining these systems is a lot
of time and it takes a lot of time and
effort and if it's not really core to
your business uh then that time is
really probably better spent building
what actually differentiates your
product
right that's something that really
resonates with me because I'm primarily
focused on Google kubernetes engine and
open source kubernetes and I'm also
involved with the cloud native Computing
foundation so in Cloud native
Technologies especially with these large
distributed systems can span both space
and environments sometimes it gets
really difficult to solve this
observability challenge so I'm excited
to learn more about this so you've
talked a little bit about how this
solution helps companies and what it's
designed to do could you take me through
what it's like to be a user of
chronospheres platform definitely I kind
of think that that Journey as a user is
a kind of reflective of that same
experience that I mentioned that the
team saw at Uber aware these companies
are making these transitions to uh Cloud
native patterns and they're kind of
seeing the uh you know the scale and
complexity that comes along with it and
there's kind of two perspectives of that
journey I think
um one is from the businesses themselves
and the other is kind of from the people
that are interacting with these systems
so as a business uh you know you
probably want to store metrics about
your applications and your business for
months or even years but now if you're
running all these thousands of
containers that are constantly moving
around where some of them really might
only exist for a matter of minutes or
seconds then you probably don't need all
of that for both data about each one of
them for the same amount of time that
you want to know important data about
your business so uh with chronosphere we
make it really easy to kind of control
how that data is stored how long it's
stored for and we often see a lot of
companies uh coming to or coming to us
when they are kind of seeing these
problems themselves uh you know if it if
their systems don't make it easy to kind
of control that then their costs pretty
much increase exponentially uh as they
continue storing all this data and also
the kind of scale of all this data is
really challenging as well it's not it's
not a simple task to store all of it to
make it quickly available to users and
as a business you really want your your
users to be able to uh you know debug
issues more quickly and kind of get to
the bottom of issues faster and that's
kind of the business perspective and I
think from the end users of the product
uh it's a lot of a lot of the problems
that they're facing are kind of the same
ones that we talked about with you know
the with these Cloud native patterns and
all this complexity like you said
um you know as a user if if your
observability systems aren't kind of
helping show you what data is important
and what's important to you then you're
kind of just bombarded with information
and it's not easy to keep up with all
this complexity so with chronosphere
throughout we call collections we really
tailor the experience of the product to
each individual user based on either
what services they own what teams
they're on to kind of make that user
experience more friendly and less
overwhelming to be honest
and also you know like I said help
people get to the bottom of issues more
quickly you know if being on call is
already stressful enough uh you kind of
don't want to have to go searching for
the needle in the haystack you want your
tools to really help you find it
um and so that's kind of what it feels
like to be an individual user is for the
product to really help you know all this
information more quickly and in a more
organized manner I love that you
mentioned the storage perspective of
this I come from a storage background so
there's so much that you want to know
about your systems when you're running a
business and all of that really does add
up over time like you said the costs can
really just kind of escalate
um so that's something that I hear from
customers a lot today as a developer
Advocate working with these Cloud native
systems and companies adopting the cloud
is that's a major concern from for them
as they Implement their observability
platforms is how do they get all the
data they need and at a price that they
can manage and then actually find the
things that they need within it so I'm
excited to hear how chronosphere is kind
of trying to address those issues so
we've talked about what chronosphere
does and all the value that it gives to
its users now how does it kind of work
behind the scenes and how does Google
Cloud fit into it definitely I think you
know there are a few aspects of our
business and our product that we've
talked about so far that really informed
how we ended up building on Google Cloud
so one we're building this platform for
uh observability into cloud-native
environments two our users are using us
as a really Mission critical service and
so we have to have strong guarantees
around our slas availability reliability
and performance as well as actually
Meeting those slas and three honestly a
lot of the data that people are omitting
about their environments and care about
is really useless if it's not available
pretty much immediately so for those
first two reasons kind of adopting a
cloud native mindset and helping build a
reliable and scalable platform we
decided to build on top of Google
kubernetes engine or gke so our
collector agent is kubernetes native
which means that when you install it in
the kubernetes cluster it automatically
discovers all your workloads and starts
Gathering data from them and then in the
product you can treat your clusters or
kind of any other arbitrary
grouping as visual groupings in the UI
and then also it'd be kind of
hypocritical if we were building this
Cloud native product and weren't
adopting Cloud native practices
ourselves so that also informed our
decision to use kubernetes
um but for some of those uh guarantees
around reliability and scalability gke
has been helpful really helpful there as
well so we can leverage gcp having
multiple zones in every region and
offering zonal isolation and we can kind
of tie that in to how we Define our
applications in kubernetes so we can
make sure that our applications are
evenly distributed across zones that our
data stores are isolated from each other
and can tolerate zonal failures
um and kind of leveraging those
Primitives but then at the same time uh
you know just running on kubernetes
doesn't really automatically make you
scalable or reliable or tolerant to
failures so like I said it's kind of
leveraging those uh abstractions
kubernetes gives us and tying those into
our own data plane as well but overall
leveraging uh G or gcps high
availability and zonal isolation and
expressing those requirements with
kubernetes has allowed us to keep or to
set a really high SLA as well as have uh
really the best performance against that
SLA in the industry
um and finally the that third
requirement of you know we're building
this product where uh the latency of
data really matters the freshness of
data for that reason we decided to
leverage Google Cloud load balancers uh
specifically the global load balancers
for getting traffic to and from users so
that means that uh data that users are
sending us uh is sent there is uh
captured from them as close to them as
possible uh
that when they go to query they or when
they go to query data from the product
uh that it's getting to them as fast as
possible as well so this means that when
users load the product they see data
that's coming from their environments
pretty much immediately which is really
important if you're debugging some
stressful issue in real time and your
the tool isn't really helping you access
all that data immediately
um so we kind of call this time to Glass
which is how we measure how long uh a
data point takes from being admitted to
being visible to a user and we try to
keep that within a view within a few
seconds because pretty quickly it can
become almost useless
this is really exciting for me to hear
about as a gke developer Advocate
because it's a really cool gke use case
where you're using kubernetes I love how
you dove into a little bit there
um a little bit about the availability
of your application and how kubernetes
helps you achieve that and you also
mentioned kind of some of the
limitations of kubernetes and how you
help to address those with your product
and as well as kind of with how you've
designed your architecture I think
that's something really important for
folks to hear about because a lot of
folks as they're adopting kubernetes I
am often telling them right at the
beginning like here are the basics of
kubernetes but at some point as you're
adopting this you're going to hit some
barriers where you're going to have to
learn a bit more and think about other
tools and things like that but one thing
I want to dive into a little bit more
there and kind of review since you
covered so much awesome stuff there is
the availability piece you mentioned a
few different things that you do to make
sure that your application is highly
available using gke such as like zonal
and other high availability
considerations could you go over that a
little bit more or kind of review it
again definitely
um so when users send us data we don't
consider that data to have been
persisted until
data stores in at least two out of three
zones within a region have acknowledged
it and that's where it's really
important for us to be able to tell
kubernetes that we need certain
workloads or certain subsets of
workloads to be in certain zones and
also where it's really helpful that gke
ensures that that information is
propagated all the way down to the data
store layer by making sure that our
persistent disk volumes are in those
zones as well
so like I said when a user kind of sends
us data we send it to data stores in
each of three zones within region and
then once two of them have acknowledged
it we consider that data to be
successfully persistent awesome one
thing that I think is really hard for
folks when they're starting to
understand kubernetes is this separation
of the application and its data which it
sounds like you all have architected for
really nicely here and this also the
availability components you were
mentioning there kind of remind me of
some of the things I talk about with gke
autopilot mode where we actually have an
SLA on pods as long as
and the kind of the caveat to that is
that you have to think a little bit
about deploying those pods in a highly
available way it's really exciting for
me to hear that you all are thinking
about availability like this and doing
all these things to make sure it's
happening definitely and you know none
of this stuff gke or kubernetes
generally are a Magic Bullet so like you
said you know there's a lot of things
that sometimes you have to dive a little
bit deeper to and uh learn you know how
it best fits your application but if you
do that honestly the benefits uh at
least for us have been really worth it
awesome
so we've talked quite a bit about how
your observability platform can help
businesses store their data and be able
to find the data that they need when
they need it and how it's architected on
the back end to be highly available and
you've put so many really nice
considerations into it but what
technical enhancements to your
architecture for this product are you
considering for the future yeah we're
always trying to improve on kind of all
the things that differentiate us whether
it's performance reliability or cost and
cost efficiency so I think looking
forward a lot of our Advanced our
advancements are going to be around
continuing to invest in those things
continuing to make sure that our product
can withstand all sorts of crazy failure
scenarios and continuing to make sure
that we can provide the lowest uh lowest
cost and best cost for performance for
cost available to our customers so a lot
of that includes you know keeping track
of what new storage technology use or
networking Technologies Google is coming
out with ensuring that we're leveraging
those properly to kind of meet those
demands for our customers as I mentioned
earlier I've encountered a lot of
customers a lot of folks who are
adopting Cloud native practices they're
running significant systems in the cloud
and they're hitting these kinds of
issues that we've been talking about and
might be interested in the solutions
that chronosphere provides so how can
folks learn more about chronosphere if
they want to learn more about your
Solutions yeah honestly the best place
is our website
chronosphere.io and and there you can
kind of see some of the problems that
we're helping users solve as well as you
know some of the techniques that we use
to help them solve it and really meet
all of those differentiators that I
mentioned earlier there's also a
Marketplace offering yes we are also
available on the gcp marketplace so you
can check out our offering if you search
chronosphere on the gcp marketplace and
learn more there as well as sign up if
you're a gcp customer
awesome so we'll make sure to have
information about that in the
description below as well thank you so
much for having me this is fun thank you
so much for joining us today I hope you
enjoyed learning about observability
with chronosphere be sure to like And
subscribe and we'll see you next time on
architecting with Google Cloud
foreign
[Music]